Hey everyone, we are going to be looking at ...
surplus, what it means and why it matters.
Now to do this.
We always want to keep in the back of our minds that ...
when we have voluntary transactions between two ...
people, could be a person in a firm or ...
just two people who are exchanging one good for ...
another service or something like that,
the thing to keep in mind is that when we have those ...
voluntary transactions, we create surplus through it.
So that is what we want to be looking at as we're going ...
through our story right here.
And welcome to Taco Land where we like to sell tacos ...
and we like to eat tacos.
But I guess we think about tacos all the time because ...
our houses have taco shaped roofs to them.
So here in Taco Land we're have people who are ...
engaging in the buy and sell tacos,
are going to be doing this voluntarily.
So they're going to be creating wealth by doing so.
Now we're going to be introduced to Maria here.
And Maria likes making tacos so much that she creates too many tacos.
Now what Maria needs is to have some customers who ...
would like to engage in some voluntary transactions.
Because the key idea here is to move lower valued assets,
in this case tacos, to higher value uses which ...
will be selling those tacos that would be making Maria ...
some profit in which she would create wealth.
And so that's our goal with surplus,
is to create wealth, wealth.
So Maria has these tacos that she needs to get rid of.
And luckily Alex dreams about tacos.
He lives in Taco Land, he has a taco roof.
So yeah, he's dreaming about those tacos.
So we need to get Maria and Alex together.
And when we do that, we can create some voluntary transactions.
So look, right here we happen to have ...
Maria and Alex.
They've kind of changed the way they look.  I don't know.
But anyway, Maria is going to sell these ...
tacos at $4, while Alex has a willingness to pay of $5.
So the market price there, $4,
both of them agree on that because for Maria,
it might only cost her $3 to make those tacos.
So these two individuals get together,
they have this voluntary transaction to buy and sell a taco for $4.
This is how we create wealth in a society,
because two people, one who has a willingness to ...
sell, the other who has a ...
willingness to pay, they get together at an ...
agreed upon price and when they do,
they generate surplus, which we also call wealth.
Now what does this all mean?
Well, Alex had consumer surplus,
what the consumer is willing to pay minus the price so ...
Alex was willing to pay $5, and the price was $4.
So Alex enjoyed a surplus of $1.
That is money that Alex can now use on other things.
That creates wealth for Alex.
Maria has producer surplus, the price minus what the ...
producer is willing to sell or the cost that it is to make the item.
In this case, the product price of taco was $4.
And we had Maria making these tacos at $3 each.
So again, that's a $1 difference.
Then you bring those together and you have your ...
total surplus, which is the combination of ...
consumer surplus and producer surplus.
Now, when we have voluntary ...
transactions, when we have free exchange ...
of these voluntary transactions,
there are no price distortions like what we're going to see later.
Then we maximize the total surplus inside that market.
And also that's when we don't have market power and ...
other market distortions.
That is when we have a perfectly competitive market ...
that's taking place, we can maximize the total ...
surplus inside of the economy,
which then is going to lead to more wealth inside of that ...
economy as well.
And so if you look at what the different market prices here ...
are, you look at Alex's and Maria's ...
willingness to pay and willingness to sell,
we can see what the surplus is.
At a price of $6, we see that Alex is willing to ...
pay, willingness to pay his $5.
Maria's willingness to sell is $3.
Well, there's no.
There's not going to be any market transaction that takes ...
place because Alex is not willing to pay $6 for that ...
particular taco.
He's only willing to pay $5.
So no surplus is generated if you go down to a price of $2.
Alex is. Yes,
Alex is willing to pay that $2 price for that taco.
But look at Maria.
Maria's not willing to sell because what it costs to ...
make that one tacos $3 at a market price of $2,
Maria is going to be kicked out of that market because ...
she's not willing to sell at a market price of $2.
But at the other market price of $5,
$4 and $3, we do see that surplus is generated.
Alex is willing to pay $5.
So he may or may not actually get into this exchange.
I'm going to say that he is.
If he's willing to pay $5, the market price is $5,
and he's going to pay the $5.
But he gets no surplus.
He only gets the enjoyment of eating the taco.
Meanwhile, Maria over here still will sell ...
that taco at $5 and enjoy a $2 surplus.
So all the surplus goes to Maria.
In this case, at a market price of $4.
Alex is willing to pay 5, so he enjoys $1 in surplus.
Maria is willing to sell at 3, so she also enjoys a $1 surplus.
Add those two together and we get $2.
At a market price of $3, Alex is going to get all the ...
surplus because he's willing to pay 5.
He buys it for 3.
That's $2 in surplus for Alex.
Maria's willing to sell it at three,
but she's not going to get any surplus from it because that's her cost.
So this is how we can see how surplus is generated for ...
one party, the other party for both ...
parties, for no parties.
I mean, we could have something in ...
there that wouldn't work for either one of them.
I don't know if we could or we couldn't.
But we can see how consumer and producer ...
surplus are generated and how that combines into our total surplus.
So everybody's very happy in taco land.
At this market price of $4, you can see that this is ...
leading to a bright sunny day and we're going to be ...
growing this economy.
People are just very happy about it.
Now, what are our key takeaways about surplus?
Well, we know voluntary trade ...
moves goods from lower value to higher value uses.
Like what we saw with Maria moving that lower value taco ...
at $3 for her to a higher value,
selling it at $4 and earning some surplus.
And those types of transactions create wealth.
They grow the economic pie, which is what we would like to see.
Now some other things for the customers.
Look for the deals where your consumer surplus is the biggest.
This is how we generate more consumer surplus for ...
ourselves, create more wealth for ...
ourselves, negotiate better deals.
If you can negotiate a better deal,
then you can lead to a price decrease that's going to ...
increase your own surplus.
And then lastly, prioritize your purchases ...
where the surplus is going to be the highest.
Look for the deals where you generate a higher level of ...
surplus for the firms.
What do we get price strategically to capture as ...
much of that consumer surplus as possible.
If you can look into what the market data is telling you and ...
then price accordingly so you can extract as much ...
consumer surplus as possible and turn it into ...
producer surplus.
Find high surplus customers and target them.
You know, if you do a lot of first class ...
flying, maybe the company who you ...
fly with might start to notice and they might start to look at ...
some of the data behind what you're doing because you are ...
a high surplus customer.
And in this case they're going to want to target you.
You're going to turn, they might give you some ...
kind of deal to entice you into more flying and then ...
communicate value, not just the price.
And what we mean by this is if you make consumers ...
perceive that there's more value into the product that ...
they are getting, then guess what they may ...
think, okay,
this $10 item is actually worth 15.
And it puts more value into it, makes that consumer want to ...
purchase that product at a slightly higher price,
and that helps the firm capture more of that ...
consumer surplus.
And that is it for our surplus.
Hope you've enjoyed it and we'll catch you in our next one.